كوريا الشماليه تنهي لعام 2022
باطلاق تجارب على ثلاثه صواريخ بالسيا وهو
عدد كبير لاطلاق الصواريخ في يوم واحد
استعراض للاسلحه مع تصاعد التوتر في شبه
جزيره الكوريه بعدما اتهمت سول جارتها
الشماليه بتسير خمس طائرات مسيره عبر
الحدود للمره الاولى منذ خمس سنوات وردت
بارسال طائرات مسيره نحو الشمال
لا يمكن تحمله كما صرح رئيس كوريا
الجنوبيه
مهددا كوريا الشماليه بعواقب وخيمه جراء
تلك الاستفزازات وتعذيذه شبكه الدفاع
الجوي لبلاده مع التعهدي بالتعامل الصارم
مع استفزازات في كوريا الشماليه كما وصفت
هيئه الاركان المشتركه عمليات الاطلاق
بانها استفزاز خطير يقود السلامه الدولي
مع تشديد سول بمراقبته تحركات كوريا
الشماليه عن قرب بالتنسيق الولايات
المتحده قوه نوويه كما يصفها رئيسها كيم
جونغ اون فبيونغيان اختبرت هذا العام اكثر
من 70 صاروخا شملت اطلاق صواريخ بالسيه
عابره للقارات تحضروا عقوبات الامم
المتحده اختباراتها
ومهما يكون من امر فان التوترات في شبه
جزيره الكوريه واليابان سيرحل للعام
الجديد بتصعيد غير مسبوق قد يفتح ازمه
جديده تضاف لما يحدث في اوكرانيا